[Music]
it's anti-climatic really isn't it
is it because i'm southern there is
absolutely no privacy
in this room whatsoever because i know
where it's going man you get all your
cash i like your trepidation with that
that's his job
this is so out of the ordinary look at
this i know we're in blackball now i've
just got a feeling on a
seagull on my car mate this is good
[Music]
hey my name's samuel leeds i'm a
self-made multi-millionaire
and people often say it's because i got
lucky
and i believe that being rich has
nothing to do with luck
statistically if you win the lottery
you'll lose the money again
and also statistically if a rich person
loses everything
they will make back the money because
it's not about luck it's about their
mindset
and it's about their skills so i've
decided in this documentary to do a
social experiment where i will move
to one of the poorest towns in the uk go
and live in someone's house
who has nothing no money at all and see
if
i can teach them my knowledge and my
skills and see if i can make a poor
person
become rich in one week let's see what
[Music]
happens my name is glenn kirkham
i'm 34 i live in blackpool i came to a
crash course in february
and had my mind absolutely blown
i got the opportunity to work on the
eviction prior to that i thought you had
to have lots of money
and i'm from a working class town i'm
from blackpool i'm a father of three
i don't own any property i write stupid
songs about footballers
for a living in december last year i got
diagnosed with a
schumer the size of a jaffa orange
which came totally out of the blue
and it's pretty terrifying
because you always think it'll happen to
someone else
and then when it happens to you you
everything changes my purpose which is
to ask you one question
and that is will you allow me to be the
person that you do the financial
freedom challenge with i saw the video
that samuel put on his youtube channel
saying that he's looking to go to
someone's house
and work with them and make them
financially free and i thought
that has to be me like whatever happens
that has to be me so
i found out when his next crash course
was and i went down to london and
i was really nervous i stood up got a
microphone and i asked the question
would would you allow me to be the one
to do the financial freedom challenge
with
and everyone just started clapping
[Music]
and as soon as i started talking about
my health and my situation and my
finances
i feel like that i felt a real release
that everyone kind of saw in me
the pain that i'm in and the struggle
that i'm going through at the moment
and i felt really lifted and when samuel
said yes
i just knew that
you know the rescue boat had come to
save me i'll come to your house
[Applause]
so we're here in blackpool i went to his
house he wasn't in
but i think i know where he is in the
pub over here
so let's go and find glenn and uh pull
him out the club and get started on this
financial freedom challenge man
this is blackpool saying man oh yeah
know if you didn't
do well yeah i can't believe it
i can't believe you're here you put
yourself out there like i have done my
whole life you know you're always a
black sheep if you try and achieve
something
everyone around you is saying be careful
you know don't take risks don't go
you know and i'm just i'm sick of it i'm
just at a point where i think
why not you have to be careful but what
this is what i'm saying what
i don't know what i don't have to be
careful
i appreciate her advice and i appreciate
her trying to look out for me
i think ultimately you need to take
advice from people that you want to be
like
exactly i'm just sick of it i just want
i want more from my life yeah
so can i see more my bedroom or on the
couch
this is my bedroom yeah dude this is
like amazing
i can't believe you've just got see
straight away
is this your spare bedroom yeah why
don't you just rent this out because
i've got three kids running around the
house constantly
there is absolutely no privacy in this
room whatsoever
well if it's good enough for me to sleep
in
matt you could rent this room out yeah
but you're here for a week you're not
here for
a year right the truth that you just
don't wonder right now i don't want to
run out
but the thing is if you want to be
financially free you've got to prepare
to do whatever it takes
if he really was prepared to do whatever
it
takes
he'd ran
[Music]
so we stayed up till early hours of the
morning i really wanted to get to know
glenn understand his family understand
his goals
but more importantly even though he'd
already been to the free property
investors crash course so his property
knowledge was decent
he didn't have any experience he hadn't
got any deals he didn't have any money
so we really needed to get him up to
speed and trained up on no money down
deals
lease option agreements rent to rent
deal packaging
but more importantly how to negotiate
and speak to estate agents to get deals
he needed to become excellent in this
area because although i was going to be
with him and i was going to assist him
ultimately i couldn't do it for him and
he was the one that needed to do the
work
i think so we need to go in the state
agency we've only got
a week not that long if we call an agent
and book a viewing it's going to be at
least
probably tomorrow before we can see it
yeah
i think if we just go inside the estate
agency i think we could pitch them on
the idea of giving us a
buy refurbished finance deal when you
say yes i'm buying it cash i've got the
cash yeah
you're talking on behalf of your
investor right okay
so but at the moment they don't need to
know who that is
okay does that make sense yeah yeah so i
go in there as if i'm as if i'm buying
it
yeah basically yeah and you will be able
to because
you'll be able you've got the resources
or will have
to be able to bring in investors and
stuff like that into the deal yeah
also really important if they're like
clueless and they're just like
oh i'm not sure all this don't try and
force it if they're rubbish
and there isn't even a manager in there
that can help you yeah we just should
just leave and go to another age and say
we might have to go into ten
agencies before we get a really good
relationship but i always i always think
that a good relationship is better than
a good deal
[Music]
oh yeah nice to meet you i'm glenn nice
to meet you this is
samuel we're looking for properties that
are
relatively cheap that we can refurbish
and pull a lot of our our money out yeah
if you got much on your bucks
yeah yeah we do have plenty to finish up
you put on the properties are they sort
of rental standard
you know for the family rent rent rental
rental standard do you remember
yourself yeah i mean the ideal scenario
is that
you go in with cash you put the money
into to refurb it
and then when you refinance it after it
you can take all of that money out so
you can just effectively recycle
over and over again so anything that has
a motivated vendor a motivated seller
that would be
you know interested in taking a deal on
something definitely
lieutenant right someone's telling me as
well
that's right generally speaking in this
sort of area
a lot of the time these smaller flats we
tend to see that they can be
sort of house benefits but again there's
people who are working who
you know read these smaller boxes as
well if you're single person
i like i like your trepidation with that
because i felt exactly the same because
when we were talking about it
you go you go that side of whitegate
drive and it's like quite professional
and quite you know
you know more higher class and then you
come this side of it and it's
you know council tenants and you know
jeremy kyle vibes
so it looks very similar to this house
here it's on the same road it's number
nine it's going on the market in the
region about 90 to 95
000 and we sold this one which is pretty
much the same house 125
and that one still needed work doing to
it it wasn't it wasn't great at all
okay and
yeah it does need it doesn't either
record spending on it i'd say if you
spent
20 to 25 and it could we could probably
put it back on for about 150. that's
what i'd recommend
25 gram refurb 150 grand new value
yeah with the 90 grand purchase price
he's probably correct
because that's his job yeah we need to
get a builder in the house to confirm
the 25 grand refurb
and then we need to go online and search
what the house
prices are doing and we need to get an
evaluation done on that 146 he's right
oh my goodness it was bought for 146
in 2005 and now it's selling
it's selling as a repo that needs work
for 90 grand dude
and he said the reefer was about 20 20
25 000 right
so if we buy it for 90 and spend 20 25
grand on it
mate you could potentially pull out all
your money this could be
a no money down deal that we found the
first morning of
and what time is it right now now it's
10
10.57
10.57 and there's a deal with with
it sold for 146 grand it reckons it's
worth 157
which is the rent 650. so it's a
semi-detached it's 90 n
so it's 90 in plus 25 plus 25 plus all
your legals and stuff about 115.
are you reckoning you're in 420 and then
revalue it at 150 160
but 157 maybe you're gonna pull out you
might leave five grand in
that let's let's drive to it another
look and then let's get some builders
out to it
let's do it but mate and you found this
this
agent this morning i don't know day one
my just
friggin touch let's go let's go
you do realize you've got the miners
touch on you if you've got such a
confidence about you when you're going
to the state agents
you wouldn't know that you hadn't bought
a million houses before
which is pretty cool i think you've
i think one of the things that i've
learned is that
if you go in there with the mentality of
i'm really scared and i don't know what
i'm doing and actually you shouldn't
listen to me because i don't own any
houses
it just comes across doesn't it see this
area feels really nice
it is it's it's a really good little
residential area very quiet as you can
see a little cul-de-sac
you won't get and and this a rent this
is it number nine here
oh mate that's going to rent out all day
long it's in the window it's a
repossession so we'll just say
no that's that's standard oh it looks
like a state
perfect so the question
the question is num we've got two things
number one is
we need to get a builder in there to
confirm that it's only gonna cost 20 25.
there could be all kinds of issues that
we've not seen yeah then secondly once
we've done that we need to then decide
how we're going to buy this
are you going to buy it are you going to
sell it i don't have i don't have 90 000
i don't have 90 000 pounds to buy it all
to do the refurb if there's a creative
way that we can do it yeah it makes
sense as a deal it makes sense
it's in a really good area it's actually
a really nice house from the outside
it's just completely unloved because
what's happened this is a repossession
so that means that someone
was not able to pay their mortgage
payments and they've been kicked out by
the
by the bank so they've probably gone off
in a bit of a strop
they've they've trashed the property and
now the bank's thinking oh
we now need to shift this so they're
selling it at a really low price because
it needs work
the bank doesn't have time to do it up
until so the bank are just selling it
off cheap
because they want they want to get their
money back so we're going to come in
buy it at a good price no one can view
this property we can't view it but it
doesn't matter
because as long as we can send our
builder it's all about formulas not
feelings
send that builder do the math see if it
works cash offer
and then we can work out how we're going
to finance it but i'm
very very excited about this property i
love it how many people will be willing
to walk into an estate agent at nine
o'clock on a monday
morning and go what have you got because
we had to look through a few in order to
find a decent one and and
yeah all right obviously with you sat
there it's quite intimidating because
you can see it and you know everything
that's going on
but you can you can see a house like we
saw two flats that were renting out for
400 pounds each that was a
fantastic deal and we saw this that
looks like a great deal
it looks great we really really make we
really like it honestly it looks perfect
for what we're after
i've just spoke to a builder and i'd and
i'd like for you to meet him
and show him around tomorrow if possible
also regarding those regarding those
flats we're going to go and do a bit of
investigation on that
now so is there any chance you can email
me
the the address and some details
about it yeah sure well i've just spoken
to the landlady actually that's
happy if you if you want you can show me
around yourself tomorrow
yeah perfect yes it's all coming up
milhouse
doing tomorrow at the apartment with the
landlord director which is perfect
because it means if you want us to try
and negotiate like lease option
all that sort of stuff with the agent
direct yeah builder is looking like 90
is going to come off we're going to have
he's got the building out there tomorrow
mate this is good and it's morning one
morning frigging one what it's amazing
what can happen in a place of like a few
hours
need to yes but more viewings and find
estate agents and continue getting deals
but clearly there's deals to be had here
absolutely
so we know we're going to get deals all
i think towards the end of the week
we need to book a like we need to go to
london
and we need to go meet as many property
investors
as we can that have got money and we can
go hey you're from london you've got
money
guess what i live in blackball where the
houses are much cheaper
guess what i know the area at the back
of my hand guess what i've got loads of
friends of agents and i've got all these
deals
do you want to do a so we need to get to
london but first we need to keep getting
the deals but i think we should even
maybe now book some london events
for the end of the week because i know
where this is going man
sometimes people get lured into like oh
i like this area yeah oh we've got a
nice garden there's a nice park
yeah but the bottom line is it's it's
all about how much you buying it for how
much you've written out for
what's my return on investment we're
gonna need some money yeah
so we're gonna need to while we're
looking for these deals
some some of the deals that we find
we're going to sell okay to get some
quick cash
yep how would you feel about having
like making three four five grand over
the next few days
i work my my backside off
and don't earn anywhere near that yeah
in a month but you're so smart
this is so out of the ordinary for
someone
of of my age in this town who
you know it just doesn't happen what's
happening right now what you're talking
about now
to me even though you've done it in the
past for yourself
i there's still an element of me which
doesn't believe that it's possible
all right so my goal incredible in the
week is i think we should do
six deals okay we should package and
sell two deals just six
just six in in seven days just the six
six deals and i'm not saying it's
definitely gonna happen but this is our
goal
right we package and sell two okay you
get some cash flow yeah it's gonna give
us enough cash flow for the two rent to
rents
yeah and the loot option it's five and
then you buy it you become a homeowner
how do like lead the way mate we've got
a house to go and see now
yeah gonna have a look yeah mate you're
an awesome guy
all right anyway let's go
oh god
[Music]
is
so what did we think of that house then
glenn uh it's absolutely massive
the potential is huge you could pretty
much double your money on it
but there is so much wrong with it like
i felt like i was on a boat
does that much she called historical
subside and she well
she's yeah she said it probably is but
who knows
one two five that's old for yeah just
know why no 300 000 you're not getting
300. so what have we learned
estate agents will massively overvalue
talk basically is what you're saying
they can
i'm beginning to like
i'd blackpool thought here's what i
think about blackpool here's what i
think about blackpool
i think if you don't know what you're
doing yeah and you just like oh it looks
cheap dump money into it yeah
it blackpool could be awful but there
are some really good areas
and there are some really good
investments opportunities if you know
what you're doing absolutely if yeah
if you're doing it it's fine because you
know the area you're local yeah but if
i just think you need to be careful
mm-hmm but i'm getting into like that i
absolutely agree
what do you reckon it would be worth one
i mean i would put a ridiculous offer
but but but you know it would be below
sixth day yeah you wanted cash
if we were just cash it would probably
be around 50 about
52 they may you can always put it
forward and see what they say
we have we've got some really good
refurb opportunities the problem is are
we going to sell them are we going to
try and raise the finance and keep them
we're becoming cereal property investors
this is nice though
is this something for 60 is it 16 yeah
it's nice it's good condition isn't it
oh my god i've never been down here this
is do you ever want to come down oh my
god no
gosh people are just like coming out in
the dressing gowns
oh my i feel like i feel like i'm about
to get
jumped at this house
it's just horrible i'm scared to be out
here in broad daylight
what's that yeah oh okay
it doesn't look too bad what what's this
one for again
because even if this was done up really
well it would only be worth what 65
yeah it's going to cost at least 10 to
do up
i don't think anything's fresh in this
house mate
oh man
look there's kids on the
are
they
roof
they're gonna break us your tires are
about to get slashed
sorry all right oh i'm gonna go
i'm sure to someone it will be a nice
home rental area
i appreciate your time mate no you're
welcome thank you very much very much
thank you so much i'll see you later
see you mate that was awful what kind of
tenants are you going to attract
exactly no man the thing is that one was
on for 55.
but there's another one on the same
street that's on for 60 that's the
immaculate
so it's just not worth just not worth it
and he knew that we certainly got quite
a good turnover of
investor type property um so
depends exactly what you're looking for
what sort of return whether you're
looking to
to flip them i refinance and sell them
on again yeah we're looking to keep them
and create a portfolio to rent out
vitalettes um i tend to find that
personally i think that the ones where
you're willing to refinance and rent
them that doesn't have to be as big a
margin
whereas the flipped intensity needs to
be more of a margin depending upon your
builders his
costs whether the mod your margin
expectations whether we could have to
put it
put a deal together for you yeah wow
i thought he was absolutely brilliant
he's so open and honest about everything
he's like look realistically you could
get this but you might not get this
he's such a great guy definitely i love
him let's go
so this is a buy refurbished refinance
opportunity right now
that was on offer over 65 and it sold
for 67 and a half
and this is 50. okay
this is a repossession as you asked the
question yes
so this one glenn yeah it's on for fifth
day
yeah once it was done enough it probably
worth about 65
question is what you think more a little
if that was 67 and a half yeah and it
was
fair to good condition yeah
so you're not going to have to pull all
your money out but you'll be able to
pull out some of your money depends on
how much the refurb costs
well that's how the valuers usually do
it unless they're numpties normally
yeah normally comparables aren't a bad
guide
subject to there being no massive issues
like the refurbing within 20 grand
i mean we could put forward an offer
i don't want to waste waste time on it
but because it's going to be fair it's
only my time you wasted itself
no i know but i just don't want to like
i was trying to piss you off i wouldn't
really cheeky off
forward but you know 43.
numbers yeah yeah i could put an offer
on 43.
it's their decision then isn't it yeah
43 is really low the thing is
the thing is unless you're embarrassed
of the offer then you shouldn't put it
forward
that is that was embarrassing like you
you did it with a style
that made it look like it was a
reasonable offer
and to be fair to make the numbers stack
it's probably going to have to go
through at 43. yeah
but we get that for 43 we are absolutely
laughing
honestly i i almost cringed on your head
43 ounces
good time to put in the offer now when
the police are right in the house yeah
you know that he always looks in our
favor you always need a you always need
to re most people go oh my gosh i'm not
going to offer on this because there's
police in the street
also i'm going to offer on this and i'm
going to offer really low because the
police on the street
yeah and when you put forward a lot of
you always need a reason steve we've not
got massive
of time in this one because we've got a
get lunch before our next viewing at 1
30.
i get a really really good feeling about
this house
i just feel really good about this this
house is amazing man it's absolutely
huge
it's in a really good area and it'll
just rent out forever
this is really good and the numbers look
absolutely amazing if what he's saying
is true
and you get it like almost half price
then
i mean you could put literally pull all
your money out of this this is i
get a really good feeling
a cash cash buy tomorrow i'd buy cash
tomorrow for 62.
uh last sale they had was 68. i know can
we try but they were messing around with
a mortgage just if i just buy cash
yeah if you put that forward but i think
you probably have 20 grand
what 62. yeah 20 grand in seven that
brings us to 82.
value at 95 we value it pull out most of
our money i think
i think i'd be happy today right so 62
on this 43 on the last one
yeah can you get that proof of funding
yes yep i can send i can get into you
today
i really really like our house i do just
got a really good feeling about it you
can tell it's solid
all right it's a bit disgusting and it
needs a lot of work on it but
it's much nicer area absolutely and i
think
if the offer works at 62 000
then i mean you do it up for 20 grand
paul likes to say way out that's the one
that's nice i like that i bet we'll get
that for like 58 grand
so with that in mind what would be the
absolute lowest that
you would take on this and still be okay
still we can't really go below 60
because we need a 10 deposit for what we
want to buy
yeah and obviously fees we've got
sellers fees and buying fees and
everything aren't we
so 60 is the absolute pretty much the
bottom that we could take
55 60 grand mark went out for five to
five yep
could be really good for you that's
going to go up in value definitely
i'm really keen to get at least up
option agreement because it's probably
the the only strategy that i could use
to
basically put no money down really what
would you say is the
lowest that you take for it and still be
able to still be all right we'll still
be comfortable with
i i'll be really happy with eight to
five is going but maybe i can go to the
84 plan
not maybe 83
83 i think i can go to them okay
because i'm running it yeah see
sometimes we would give you
your full asking price will give you the
85 in this case with two flats
i think we could even probably give you
i mean
i'd be happy to give you a hundred
thousand
but we couldn't do that for a period of
time would probably be like maybe five
years six
years with an option to purchase it but
in the meantime we take over and make
sure that you have
you know payment every month and we deal
with all the tenants it would basically
just be a completely passive
investment for you and then
[Music]
85's a bit tight for us because we need
to make money from it as well you know
no i understand but is it children's
money from their body
just offered a release option straight
off the bat she said no she needs the
money now so
the lease option's not going to work in
this situation i mean it's still a
decent return but
she's a lovely lady the only issue with
that deal is that she needs
the capital to give to her kids yeah it
won't work for a good try
but it won't work for a lease option but
we bought that for 83 yeah
he's renting out for 800 pound a month
yep
there's no bills or anything the guy's
been there 16 years the guy upstairs has
been in that house for 16
years matt i think we could sell that as
a deal yeah
two grand 50 even 1500 quid 2 grand oh
sell that for two grand
i reckon we could get it down to about
80 grand
in japan a month the return on
investment on that's going to be about
25 percent easy
okay there will be people who want that
all day long that's cool i like that
i think we should the only problem here
is this is the catch-22 what comes first
the chicken or egg
do we offer on the property and get it
accepted at 80 grand or 82 grand or
whatever
yeah and then try and sell it or do we
sell it on the basis that we know we
could get it for 80
and then go back and hope that it's
still available
why would you do it that way right
because the way to do it is to sell it
is to is to now we're on it no because
no because have you got investors ready
to buy that
no but you've always said if the deal is
good enough you'll find the person you
will but as soon as we offer on that and
it's accepted i guarantee you within
hours
the agent will be phoning us breathing
down our neck saying i need your proof
of funds i need your id
and then it's like you know what i'm in
so we need to find an investor for that
now
how do we do that how are we going to do
that
let's talk about when we get home all
right let's go
she did say though about the lease
option agreement that i tried to offer
her she was like
i didn't need the money to move she said
i'd take that offer
i found this property yeah it's six
bedroom terrace house
okay it's 100
is it 23 500. is it an auction
no it's just 120
500 but yeah it's it's
a four bed upstairs no just look at it
yeah it's a four bed upstairs a two bed
downstairs
which means you could do the downstairs
there's a flat and the upstairs is a hmo
all right all right so we've expressed i
don't like them at
all it's not on an auction but i'd be
surprised
if he will go anywhere near that price
but we can view it why why do you
why do you think because express estate
agency how they work because they put
properties on really low but then
they've got guide price
and then they tell the seller oh you'll
get way more and then they're trying
how long has it been on the market 2017
okay
interesting interesting that he
it could be a good lease option is that
what you were thinking because
he's in negative equity for one five
five yeah
see if you said to him he bought it for
one five five he can't sell it
he now's trying to sell it for one two
three or maybe maybe more
he just wants his money back so be
interesting to see if he's currently
renting it out
i think this could be good also the fact
that it's all of express aspect agency i
wonder if we can talk to him direct
all right cheers see ya bye
so it's a great property the vendor's
gonna show us round yeah we've got we've
got a viewing in an hour
so if we can get this it's like every
single criteria that you talk about at
the crash course about what you need for
a lease option
he's got negative equity yeah
i and there's there's a two bed flat
which you'll get about
500 a month for and upstairs
there's a four bed hmo but it says here
they're under they're two separate deeds
they're two separate titles mate
you did very well for one in there it's
been on the market a while the thing
that's going to make this a deal breaker
be obviously assuming that we can get
the vendor on side
is it looks great on the pictures yeah
but doesn't look like that in real life
this is nice this so this is this is
christmas is two apartments two flats is
it there's one downstairs two bed
quite a big one uh big land big kitchen
this one
is a four bed yeah and this is always
two floors
what do you think this would get per
room if you had four separate tenants in
there
eight square room per week probably a
bit more but yeah
work on the low side 80 quid 320 a week
50 16 20 a month all my tenants
apart from this one here has my personal
mobile number
and if there's a problem they don't tend
to ring the agent they ring me and i get
someone to sort it straight away
and you don't need that now and i don't
really need that now
the thing with the hmo is it needs to be
a minimum of 70 square foot
per room yeah so the what's the smallest
the smallest square footage per room
in this building is that room there
that's 80.1 square feet
so all the room sizes seem to
make it work i don't understand why you
just
don't rent it out well i've been renting
it out for five or six years now yeah
and um it's got to the point where i'm
summary tired i don't want the hands-on
ex you know day-to-day work looking
after it
i could get an agent in to run it for me
um
and that's an option but uh i just want
a passive income from it then i guess
yeah i'm looking at reducing my
portfolio and
i'll keep some of the properties for
sure because it makes sense to keep them
and others i will sell on or
like chris has already said there's no
there's not really capital appreciation
in here so to make it worthwhile and i
don't want to offend you because
you seem like a really nice guy and you
should be really proud of what you've
done
but it you know it'd probably be around
a hundred hundred and two thousand
yeah let's buy it to buy cash today and
that sort of figure i won't let it go i
might as well keep it and
get a good rental income from it yeah so
if
if passive income is you is your goal
and you just want an easy life
then maybe i could offer you something
like this so i can give you a fair rent
based on what you you're paying every
single month for the for the property
itself
and with that i'd take over the
management the tenants
any any maintenance repairs anything
like that give you a fair rent
but give you the asking price that you
want and a little bit more
but in a period of time so you said you
wanted 130
000 for it for the property so
maybe maybe i could give you 140
000 but in seven years time
just to give time for the market to
recover but in that period i'll give you
a
fair rent and a fair fee every single
month
and i i know i can manage it i can
maintain it i can look after all the
tenants
you don't have to worry about it
completely hands off how does something
like that something
that doesn't sound too bad so you would
source all the tenants and do the
management of the maintenance of the
property and so forth
what kind of what kind of fee do you
think would be fair
every month to take over the whole the
whole block
i would need a couple hundred pounds a
month on top of whatever
outgoings i've got from for example you
know about a lot more reach that i've
got on it and so forth
so what do you pay everyone for that for
that mortgage uh
about 500 a month okay so a couple
hundred pounds on top so
we're talking like 700
have you got any questions um or what
questions did you have i mean
as long as this would all be tied up
legally then
yeah it sounds like it could be a good
oh could happen how about we do this how
it is
i'll i'll pay you 675 a month how much
is your insurance you're building the
challenge 22 pounds a month
i'll pay that as well so we're nine
seven yeah
and i'll pay for your solicitors fees as
well yeah so
because basically i need you to be
protected and i need i want you to feel
comfortable because
if we're gonna be working together for
seven years then everything has to be
obviously we need to know each other and
get on with each other absolutely that's
the way it will work
and it's all about transparency so out
of a goodwill gesture i'll cover the
solicitors
i'll cover the rent and i'll do the
billing insurance i'd like to do or what
i'd like to do in the future
is any any profit that i make
i'll put a contingency to one side so
about 10
a month of the revenue and then anything
that goes wrong with the property
whatsoever i'll
i'll take it out of that so that what we
don't want is
free for the profit that you make for
you to start having to pay out for
buildings and
no okay because i want to help you also
so basically
um you're gonna it will be as if it's
your property yeah effectively yeah and
you'll be as handsome
and within that seven years you've got
the right to exercise the options so
yeah for four hundred and forty thousand
and forty thousand does that
anything goes up in value but you're
trying to make money yeah you wanna make
money but you wanna have a peaceful life
yeah i'm worried about having a peaceful
part right now yeah
i know it sounds okay yeah all right all
right cheers chris okay
i'll um i'll speak to myself okay and
get all the little bits sorted yeah i'll
email you all the details that we've
talked about right
about the lease
thanks so much
oh my god man dude i can't believe it is
that a good is that a good deal do you
think that's a good deal
it's a phenomenal deal did i offer too
much
because it's not because it's 1 30 140
in seven years
no he's out too much that house if that
is not worth two hundred thousand pounds
in seven years time i'll eat
a piece of my own poo mate that's a
phenomenal deal yeah
and he understands that you're gonna be
making loads of profit
i can't believe it come on it's good man
oh man
there's about two grand a month in that
deal and i've got to pay him
basically 700 a month so 675 for the
rent
22 pound for buildings insurance that's
it
yeah good thanks how
are you fixed looking at this
service accommodation whenever you
whenever
i can go now she won't meet you there
yeah all right cool
i'll meet there in in 15 minutes
i'm just leaving while i get drive now
so okay we'll
we'll leave right now all right cool bye
this is a mate of mine it's a local
builder yeah it's a really really good
guy
right he's done really well for himself
yeah he's done
done really well for himself in
blackpool so he's looking for just like
a guaranteed rent i think so
i think so he's to be honest every time
i speak to him he's busy doing some
development or another so yeah i don't
think he
i don't think he's that interested in
renting out himself
and doing the the linen and all that
kind of stuff he just wants he just
wants a return on
that works his investment to see these
and see what i love nicely oh yeah good
to see you nice to see you
so you got three blocks in here right
yes it feels nice to be in somewhere a
little bit more
market than some of the places we've
been seeing some of the absolute dog
kennel pits we've been in
we're like really close to the center
aren't we now really close so
okay how much rent does he want for
these
five to five a month i think this one is
okay
per unit per unit i think the top one's
five three five i think there's only an
extra
well he hasn't he just said rent it out
i just want my guaranteed rent you know
i mean
you know but there's only so much you
can do so then when somebody says start
doing airbnb
making sure people come in clean it all
up after ain't got time good living here
this is
such nice quality it's great in it
stick a little table in the corner it
just works
this one is airbnb you've got three
double bedrooms upstairs yeah you know
what i mean that's what you've really
got
you know so i mean i know it's be done
as a lounge as a flat and two bedrooms
but really
it's three that's why you do one in my
opinion like he did with a
pull-out bed in the front room so it can
be a bed if they want to stay
the top flat's really good make sure
yeah
[Music]
yeah so i can take these on and rent
them out as a service accommodation
five to five per unit per month yeah
straight to you yeah till the late night
didn't you
it's good for me cool we have a deal yes
awesome
thanks cam really appreciate you man
i've just got a
rental rental service accommodation
three units 525
per unit that you reckon they'll rent
out a 200 pound a night in the height of
the season
another done deal two days in get in
so why were you very happy to do this
business with glenn then
because he's a really nice guy and he's
been up from from the beginning
yeah and you're happy for him to have
the profit even though you could do it
yourself
yes but you don't want the headache
anything thanks guys makes sense so it's
going to cost a few thousand to get that
place furnished yeah
but all we need to buy is the furniture
we can even lose the furniture we're
going to make a conservative
500 pound profit per month per unit
we've got three of them just off that
alone that is
1500 per month that's amazing
property income in your bank
just from just just from those three
deals easy as that
you don't quite believe it do you no you
don't believe it
no you're in shock man i know it was
what i'm starting to notice here is that
the barrier between actually getting the
deal and all of the viewings and all the
phone calls and stuff
he's actually just been just actually
being nice and honest with people yeah
so with him
i mean he was very upfront he was like i
don't want the hassle of it and i was
like
i even felt when i was saying to him you
know i could take it over and look after
it and
you know make sure that you get your
rent even then even then even though i
knew that i was being honest about it i
was still
had this like fear of
you know i don't know you felt like you
were being naughty or you you were like
trying to be deceitful
yeah yeah i did i did even though i know
i'm doing him a favor and he wants me to
he's been waiting for someone like me to
help him
yeah i still feel that way it's bizarre
you felt like you were being underhand
almost
even though you weren't yeah but he
knows what you're doing he just said
that he likes you he trusts you he
thinks you're
a good guy he's happy to do business
with you he's all accurate
and the reason that he doesn't want to
do it himself is because he's a busy man
he's a developer yeah
he hasn't got time since half past nine
this morning that
it's pretty much being financial freedom
yep in a day
it's crazy i can't
mad which is where's your house left
chris has another property
he has a lot of properties but he's got
another one that he's messaged me about
and he says yeah that he wants to get
rid of them they're 150 000 pounds
okay they're currently in mint condition
yeah there's a
studio one bed and a two bed
and they're going for 525
400 and 325. they're all together that's
right 12.50
and he wants 150 for it and he's not
going to take a penny lower than that
in good condition why don't we sell that
deal
yeah that's what i'm thinking and then
the money that we make yeah we need to
see it first
we need to go around chris's house yeah
i'll draw
bang up ahead to terms now go around
this house first thing in the morning
yeah you can sign the heads of terms
look around the other properties
yeah then drive to london and see if we
can sell that yes
so as soon as we've sold it we've got
some money we can then use that money
to then pay then we can save the sisters
there's your heads of terms that signed
yeah oh and it's a thousand pounds yeah
we just need to see it
yeah and if you got the address uh
it's i can get i can get it well even if
that one's not a good one we've got the
we've got the flats yeah the two market
value deal
yeah we when we're in london tomorrow
i'm pretty confident we'll make we'll
make that thousand pound at least
yeah and more so then i send that to the
solicitors yeah
and everything gets moving yes blackpool
has so bottomed out
he only weighs up and that property he's
agreed to buy it for 140 grand
in seven years seven years is a long
time are you proud are you proud of what
glenn's done yeah absolutely you knew he
could do it i knew he could do it but
i think being around you and spending so
much time with you and seeing exactly
what he comes back with
is so awesome sorry madison you can't
wear something let me ask you a question
what does your dad do
for a job he sings
and does anything else
should i tell you what he does he is a
property investor
[Laughter]
realistically i i can't actually quite
believe it
how much realistically do you think you
could generate per room
on that 90 pound a room as a minimum
yeah and they're not
none of the rooms are on suite that is a
letdown or whether that could be
alternate i don't know it's it i looked
it i said
quite quite costly to do it um but do
not be nice
to a nice standard um fully furnished
kitted out there's no reason why the
rooms won't let for 90 pound a week to
professional people
that's brilliant because i did all my
numbers on the premise that it was going
to be 80.
yeah if you said between 80 and 90 then
you're not going to be in anywhere yeah
yeah uh his whole thing was he reckons
it'll be about 2 000 quid
to do the whole thing out to dress it to
get all the beds to get the cupboards to
get everything
because it's already pretty much there
it's already absolutely brilliant
standard it just needs dressing
and his fee is 12 to look after it he
said it would definitely work as a hmo
he said it you'd probably get about 90
quid a room which is more than i thought
i could get like
conservatively so that is the deal just
keeps getting better and better and i've
got a contact in blackpool now
who i know is he understands hmos he's
already got his own portfolio
he does he's got a serviced
accommodation above his garage
that he rents out for 60 quid a night i
mean you couldn't want a more perfect
contact
hello hello how was it
really good was it don't tell us he said
to me
a hundred percent it will work as a hmo
oh
yeah wait we did our numbers on 75 to 80
pounds of room
he said you will get 90 almost
guaranteed
95 per room he said the demand in the
area is ridiculous deal
is incredible it costs 400 pounds to
dress that one room
yeah that was already done with the bed
and the
he wardrobe for everything he said you
probably you'd probably be here for
about two and a half grand
oh it's made you do the whole thing come
on
mate and he said guaranteed you'd get
ninety pound if not night
five pound a week wow which means how
much profit are you gonna make it from
that one
nobody down deal profit
rep wow total revenue is gonna be two
grand profit and i'm paying him
700 so profit about a grand yeah after
bills and stuff
900 to a thousand kids oh my god that's
the range
that is good that is amazing isn't it
did you talk to him about the rent
service accommodation
units yeah what did you think so this
was right at the end
yes i'm just about to walk out of that
so when would accommodation
oh yeah he said brilliant model he said
blackpool he said it's fantastic he said
your occupancy rate's really high yeah
and he said you know that already though
he goes have you got a minute said yeah
guys come with me
takes me through his house into his back
garden right and above his garage he's
converted it
five grand into a service accommodation
unit
and he was like this is full all the
time how much does he think you'll make
of your three
he said to me that i could get 150
pounds a night
his occupancy right probably for the
whole
for the whole block two to two and a
half grand a month so you're financially
free yeah
look at that happier about it
but to be honest and i'm going to be
honest with you it's still and i've
watched
two or three of your um on youtube
because i don't have to say you suddenly
popped up when i watched the eviction
and i still don't understand it i still
don't understand how you can go and get
a property
without having a twenty thousand pound
deposit and the solicitor's drawing up
you can't
it it baffles me and i port a lot of
houses
i've often thought something i'll be
honest that you know why didn't we just
call working morrisons
david and i have always thought you know
i'm a minute
why haven't we got a son who goes and
works in tesco's and
because in our world and that's what you
do when you leave school
you get a job you go to work you buy a
house you pay off your mortgage you
retire
and so suddenly when glenn's telling me
what he's doing with you it's like
how can that be you know yeah
i should be here celebrating the fact
that
we've done these amazing deals and i'm
not i'm i feel
worked up and i feel stressed about
searches and land registry and
you know telegraphic fees and all this
kind of stuff and i don't know what they
are and
you know what like land registry
restriction fees
bank statements and things like that
like that's my
that's what i'm feeling worked up about
and that's what i'm feeling stressed
about and i shouldn't be
i should be i should be here like
jumping around the room
at the fact that i've signed a lease
option agreement because
every property investor or everyone who
wants to get into property
wants this deal because this deal is
amazing and this deal will pour
a thousand pounds pretty much in my
account every month
maybe 800 quid in my account like this
is this piece of paper right here is
halfway to financial freedom
and it's only now do i realize i'm
intimidated by a piece of paper which is
absolutely ridiculous
but that's how i'm feeling right now the
way it the where it is at the moment
is it's gonna cost me about three
thousand pounds
it looks like it might be a bit more but
there's like
fees for for accounts and things like
that that
you know i've gotta send a check here
and scan these documents and do this
this is the stuff that doesn't really
get talked about like i feel like
in the in the training and in the
industry i'm not just saying samuel i'm
saying generally
this i feel like this stuff doesn't get
talked about like it's all about finding
the deal and getting the money
and sourcing stuff and service
accommodation and how to dress your
property nice and
i don't feel like i've ever learned
about this about the legal side of it
the the potential risk of me not doing
this
is the risk and reward is it's three
thousand pounds in
to do the deal three thousand pounds
that i don't have
and all of these hoops that i have to
jump through with these solicitors
and if i don't do it then i'll lose the
deal if i don't
spend that money then i'll lose the deal
that's going to put a thousand pound a
month every month for the next seven
years
with a chance to buy a property pretty
much
well it'll probably be about samuel says
about 60 70 000
more than what it currently is so it is
an absolute
belter of a deal
and i actually feel a bit like he's
obviously samuel was obviously annoyed
that i'm
having these like mental blocks right
now
i don't know why i don't know why i'm
feeling intimidated and like
insecure about doing these is it a pride
thing
like are you is it because you
don't want you don't want people to see
that actually you're not doing as well
as you could be or you're not as far
along as you could be
or like houses and property
actually have quite a negative like of
course quite a lot of pain and quite a
lot
of hurt and quite a lot of um like
negative emotion in my life
through parents and and relationship
like family and things like that so
maybe that's coming through maybe maybe
subconsciously
that's manifesting itself now like
it upsets me slightly that i'm stood
here with the documents in my hands
of something that i've wanted for so
long and rather than celebrating
that and rather than
being agilent and cheering and jumping
around and going we've done it we've
you know i've finally done it i've
cracked it i've done my first deal
i've done two i've done three deals i
like after this
not that it would happen but technically
i wouldn't have to work again i'm quite
a frugal guy and i could live on this
money
so why am i feeling this way i don't get
i don't understand it
i'm accessing a really raw part of my
brain right now
it's like a really uh quite an emotional
place
and i obviously need to overcome that
and i need to beat that
this is no longer a property challenge
this is a personal mountain
now that i have to overcome
i think the reason why i'm feeling the
way i'm feeling yeah
is because in my past i've had a lot of
negative
emotion and a lot of negative connection
with property yeah so
a lot of my family have had really bad
experiences with it
so we had over a dozen different houses
in our childhood whether it be rentals
or
various different places you know never
really sit laid roots anywhere
and i think i have a lot of there's a
lot of hurt
and a lot of anger and a lot of
frustration
from people that i care about more than
anything to do with property
and that's why i'm probably feeling the
way that i'm feeling now
that resistance because if that is
constantly going on in my head how can i
how can i help i think the only way
to do this is for me to just
move through the pain it's not pain but
to move through the
yeah here's the thing i'm aware of it
now
like just standing with that document
i'm aware of it
and i can see it but if that program
program's been running
my whole life then is it any wonder why
i've sabotaged myself for all this
period of time
no uh you know what you can have all the
skills you can even take action but if
you don't believe
if you don't believe in yourself and if
you don't believe in
property then you're going to
self-sabotage
and that's exactly what i've been doing
i think if i wasn't here
this week yeah all these deals i think
you would somehow
find a way of sabotaging i think you're
probably right
even more so than that i think this is
probably a thing that a lot of people
will have
i don't think i am the first and i don't
think i'll be the last
the thing is just the most likely to do
well in property yeah
you you've worked so hard up to this
point
it's just interesting for me to see
because i don't normally see this
yeah i'm not training people in property
and then because i
don't sit in their living room with them
at midnight saying how you feeling about
this
yeah i don't see this yeah so for me i'm
i'm learning a lot about
about the everyday person
yeah because you know what what's the
worst case let's say that they're not
good
yeah you can walk away yeah like
you're not even going to be paying to
map your own pocket because you haven't
got any money to pay for them
we're going to make them money this week
yeah and we're going to pay them like
you can only walk out of this a richer
better person
i agree it seems really easy to stand
there and go
so once you've got your deal and you've
done all this and you've stacked it and
everything's fine you get in touch with
your solicitor they send you the
paperwork you sign it and it's done
like i think that bit kind of gets
brushed over a little bit as because
you've done it a million times
you brush over it as oh just get your
solicitors done like i'm there reading
words going
what like what is land rich land
restriction fees like what is that i
don't know what all
those things are yeah and so i'm maybe
it's maybe it's partly inexperienced and
part going once i sign this
i know that it's real once i sign that
piece of paper
the deal is done and technically
once i sign that piece of paper i'll
never have to work again so i don't know
how much of it is
inexperienced and how much of it is
complete self-sabotaging psychology you
know what it's like
you know when someone's had bad
relationships and then when they get in
a good relationship
they're like constantly sabotaging it
and questioning it yeah
it's like financially you've had you've
had a bad relationship with money about
100
and now you've got something good you
like questioning it
and you're sabotaging it and i'm almost
expecting it
to go wrong or expecting it to not be as
so
fruitful as it is i'll tell you what
later on this week in just a couple days
i
am as you know i'm meeting up with grant
cardo
i would love for you because grant
cardone is one of the most successful
investors in the world
i would love for you to sit with grant
cardone
tell him your fears tell your problems
and see if he can
i mean i'm i'm trying man but to me you
almost feel like a lost cause at the
moment
if he can bang some sense into you when
it comes to the finances
mm-hmm i'll be really happy so are you
up for sitting
but for the time being can we just park
all this negative crap
yeah and just get on with the d you
don't have to sign it right now
but can we just move on and try and
focus on
the solution which is selling some deals
to pay for all of this yeah rather than
can we just move off and then you can
meet grant on thursday and then
hopefully he will
he'll bank some sense into you and and
confirm what i'm saying
all right man really well today i'm
thank you ridiculously impressed
thank you i couldn't have picked a
better person to do this with i don't
think you could either
[Music]
today is a massive day day four
thursday today samuel and i
are going down to london to a networking
event
my whole game is to go down there with
samuel
and pitch some of the deals that we
found this week
at half eleven yeah okay that sounds
great
wait this is great this is a great look
for you thanks man
two-bedroom house yeah right in heart
town
today i booked it in 29 minutes
the good thing is i just spoke to him
and said would they take an offer
um that's not that's not an auction and
she said yeah she said
you you'd probably get it for 55.56 and
i reckon
it's pretty nice and i reckon that i'd
rant out and look where it is hold on
look look where it is this is the town
this is the town center
it's a decent place well if you look
around the comparables are 61
74 69 yeah we can get it for 55.56
it's in our price range are you thinking
for you yeah she said that'll rent all
day
so if you can get your finance sorted
that's how much movement out for
she said about 500 505 for a 55 grand
um i would like to make an offer on
the flats that you have on please
okay what would you like to offer
82 500.
okay like an offer is 83
500. yeah there we go and without the
cash or is it mortgage
that would be mortgage oh okay
let me go with me let me speak to the
vendor and i'll call you back
okay that would be amazing thank you so
much are you welcome cheers
bye
wow i've just made an offer on a
property that i can't afford
to be fair at this moment in time i
can't afford any of this
she's just gonna have a word with a
husband okay and she's gonna get back to
you mate
okay okay
she told me on the viewing that her
husband died
she did didn't she yeah
i i i really feel deep down that that's
going to go through
that's going to get accepted it will or
do you sell it or do you bite yourself
it's so funny i just find it really
really humorous that
i'm i'm making decisions based on
the fact that i have nothing and yet i'm
like do i buy some 80 grand flats or
these serviced accommodation units
that'll bring in two grand um
i mean i'm finding this really
intimidating
not as much as the other day but i'm so
excited about this because i can see how
this would work
sammy seems to be enjoying his peanut
butter sandwich has he put the whole
thing in his mouth
may as well have done
toast sandwich and yeah some which would
be great thank
you
did you enjoy our chat last night
yeah man what i think business to one
side
what i love about you is that you just
really open and vulnerable
like you're not you don't try and be
something you're not
and sometimes in my life i've been like
oh you know portray a certain front
yeah i realized with you you don't you
just are who you are
and it's great and i've learned a lot
like not only business-wise but
personally
i love you bro we're gonna get you guys
have some deals make some money
time to go to london make some money is
she scared
i think we're all scared i think we'd be
stupid not to we're going from
taking on about a 1500 pound a month
outgoings to pretty much five or six
grand a month outgoing because i think
that would scare anyone
yeah like you're pretty much quintupling
your
your outgoings yeah and there is a
potential that it might not work
hi my name's glenn and i'm a property
investor from blackpool
if you know the area if you know the
area of blackpool you'll know
that it's one of the best places in the
uk to live there no
no what do you want to do
rather than saying if you know the area
what you do the psychology of this is
you're creating
a problem for the for the folks so
saying
if you know the area if you know the
area i genuinely believe the blackpool
is one of the most lucrative areas to
invest in property
i found four incredible deals
i'm talking 10 yields i'm talking 25
roi's you're saying that your investors
look for 10 12
15 i i have lots of them so if you want
any property in blackpool and you've got
some money to invest i can get you
some incredible returns so i'll be in
the bar come and talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that will rent all day every day for the
rest of time so
i have a finance fee and i i have a bank
to pay for all my properties
so that what will happen with that i'm
going to secure this tonight
so if you want to secure it tonight i
can give you the terms and conditions we
can go through all of the information
i'll give you everything that i can
tomorrow all of the information
pictures numbers everything if you want
to do it
that's the worst
price on that is 150
000. your studio is three to five a
month and i'm surprised
what i've spoken to people about that's
the one
yeah okay i came here with four deals so
the flats yeah i had the the two blocks
sold three out of four it's six grand in
about five i'm joking
nope i've got one left i've got chris
chris's other block they'll definitely
blow it yeah wow
why do you want to buy it yeah why do we
where's the legos where's that
nice to meet you i'm glad you're playing
a long time we're going up to blackball
monday
hey i live up there i'm
okay you're like the weirdest investors
i've ever met because no one ever wants
anybody
so my fee is 2 000 per unit because
that's what i've been telling them but
um if you're interested in it
i can send you the information but what
i'd have to do is secure it tonight
with you guys all the legals will be in
place
and then i'll put you in touch with the
agent i'll tell you everything that's
happened so far in an email chain
how much we've secured it for all of the
photos
any problems with it anything from land
red basically everything
and because i'm a man of my word when
you come to blackpool i'll come around
with you
and just say this is you know i'll be
your personal shelter for the day
i'll show you exactly what's going on is
that something you're happy with
yeah yeah for both of them uh yeah okay
fantastic all right thank you very much
pleasure
[Applause]
it's absolute pleasure thank you so much
so the moment it's flat
you're an investor you want to make
money i'm the best i want to make money
i can't i can't make this work all
around that area
is good and it's good rental as well
to kind of understand that a lot of them
aren't going to get mortgages so in a
way
it's a bios market really there you go
really good really good thanks to you
guys
thanks for shouting me out i just had
loads of people around me and i sold
all four deals within about five six
minutes
so how much money have you made tonight
provisionally
8 000 quid that's pretty good
i'm a bit disappointed because after the
fact i've realized two of the deals i
should have done for three
so probably should have ten but
eight eight grand eight grand i started
the week with nothing
so
so it's 2 30 in the morning
what a day thousand pounds worth of
deals sold
just really really hope that the money
comes in the bank tomorrow
[Music]
yes brilliant
[Music]
feels getting accepted baby deals
getting accepted money in the bank
that's cool i got a deal accepted on a
house that's never going to own
the other problem is and we've only just
become aware of this
i'm not compliant as a sorter so
samuel is what i'm doing illegal
yes well that makes things a little bit
more awkward doesn't it
yes so what do you suggest what's up
i'm not compliant as a sorcerer
i don't know what what do you need from
me
to sell them for you to invoice them
yeah
okay well how much would you take as a
as a fee
all of it um
i don't know mate uh how much you're
selling them for
two grand each
i love you
[Music]
yeah the deal's great i know they're
great they stack i've
got as much to deal with
is how do you control that fear yeah so
you know the way i i have it on every
deal
what i do is i find a great piece of
real estate and i make the worst case
the worst case possible calculation on
the deal
yeah everything up from there is like
dessert
so if you're using the right math dude
like use the fear math
be willing to press into the fear no
it's not going to go away
ever never going to go away no matter
how many people catch you on the back
no matter how many drinks you have no
matter how many accounts you get
that [ __ ] fear should never go away
it's all yours there's nobody you can
you can share try to share it with
everybody nobody's taking it with you
so the moment you tell him he's over it
you're still stuck
so it's almost like don't even try to
talk to anybody about it because it's
never going away until you sell a deal
and then you're going to be pissed off
at yourself you'll be like [ __ ]
it's a good deal number one do it but
number two if it cash flows under
any kind of economic condition then you
don't really have anything to worry
about
tell the time what happens so i've just
been in there i met grant cardone
and i asked him one question which was
how do you beat the fear and that's what
i've had this whole time
and even he gets fear and the guy's
nearly a billionaire i'm feeling so
confident the deals are good let's go
back to lightpool
let's sign the deals let's do it and
then you will be officially financially
free man come on
glenn five days i can't believe it i'm
so proud of you man
thank you both i'm so proud of you thank
you
i couldn't have picked a better person
and bring me more joy to do this with a
new man
and i couldn't have done it without you
mum thank you so much let's go sign
these deals
in blackpool let's go come on let's do
[Music]
it
samuel yep i have some news
i have some good news okay but i also
have some bad news
i finally got accepted for a loan for a
deposit
of 20 000 pounds pete how much
is that the bad news yeah it's really
expensive
it's 15 okay
i mean assuming that you could work with
a broker to use it
potentially yeah it's not but i'll be
uni i'll be earning a better interest
off my property anyway
it's not that bad what 15 all right
it's not it as long as it was like short
term and as long as you can do it
above board and i mean it's it's over
five years
it gives you options isn't it yeah i've
at least i've got options as long as you
use it really well
yeah so i've got my loan yeah and the
option of two mortgages either
residential or
buy to let so you could for instance buy
a house we bridge bridge the money yeah
use the loan yeah refurb it and then
refinance
exactly i've got i've got like you say
i've got options i can do stuff like
that that's really good news
done bro it's really good yeah yeah i'm
feeling good i feel like
we just we just need to get an offer
accepted on some houses
more houses now i know i'm excited man
my dog man cheers dude 140 000 pound
agreed
seven year term yeah everything about
the maintenance repairs
um how much 675 i'm gonna be paying you
every month
right so everything's in place yeah
let's get it
let's go
there you go okay chris absolutely
brilliant thank you man
but is it but is it subletting and
because subletting's illegal right
illegal yeah but if you use the right
contract then it's not
if i'm a manager of the property so
but if i'm the manager of the property
yeah i can't get it on like a shot
dude come here come here quick okay look
at this
[Music]
is that just coming now yeah yeah that's
the first uh
that's from my that's from the first
deal mate how's it feel
amazing so i've got another another six
to go in on top of that
that's so cool that'll be enough at
least to pay for your lease option
contracts
yeah so that's awesome man that's
awesome so that's my contract sorted
then i just need the other lot to pay
for the service accommodation
yes and then that's it then i've then
i've raised all the money love it
yo cool so today has been an amazing day
thank you everybody you've been
incredible
so seven days seven days good week
it's been wild it's been absolutely
crazy just
give me a recap give me the lowdown what
has actually happened over the last
seven days so day one so
monday we went and saw loads of estate
agents got a flavor for the kind of
areas in blackpool and the prices that
they're looking for and on the tuesday
we started viewings
started going around with agents and
loads of houses we saw
loads i think we saw about 15 in a day
didn't we so absolutely loads
um started putting a few offers in here
and there as well
but wednesday day three was the biggest
day for me because
i managed to secure my lease option
agreement which is a four bed hmo
upstairs a two bed flat downstairs which
will
generate a thousand pound a month profit
worst case scenario apart from if
there's voids but we've counted for that
it'll basically pay a grand a month
which is absolutely awesome
agreement with you managing it there
yeah yeah but still a grand a month and
they
that was the same day you also did what
got three rent-a-serviced accommodation
apartments
absolute mint in the town center perfect
location
and they absolutely worst case scenario
will be bringing in
500 pounds per unit per month which
means
the over the space of this whole thing
have generated two and a half thousand
pound a month
which is makes me financially free and
then thursday
you what happened thursday thursday a
lot of the deals that i found that were
good that obviously i couldn't buy
or couldn't do anything with i ended up
selling and got eight
thousand quid in my bank account eight
thousand from one networking event which
was amazing and
the thing is that eight thousand pounds
you're not going to be able to use that
on disneyland
no of course not that is going into my
lease option
and my rental rents to get them up to a
point where i can start letting them out
so it's
but you've now got that skill though
where you can make that kind of money in
that short time period
absolutely i can do that over and over
again now thank you to you
but i think the biggest breakthrough for
me with all of this wasn't necessarily
the
the property strategies or tactics or
anything it was more the mindset i feel
like
fear and doubt and anxiety has
controlled a lot of
what i've done in the past and that was
friday yeah i'll be self-sabotaging and
then i sat there with grant cardone
thank you for that by the way
um and he said to me it doesn't matter
whether you're doing 100 million dollar
deals or whether you're doing
you know 100 grand deals he said you're
always going to feel that pain
you're always going to feel that fear
and you just have to press into it so he
said you just got to press into that
theory
which was which was then when the
following day when we signed everything
made it all happen your loan got
approval you got your bank
um bank bank loan accepted that's it and
the biggest one of all
is that i've been accepted on two
mortgages i've been accepted for a buy
to let mortgage
and i've been accepted for a residential
mortgage as well which means
that i'm after you've been here for
seven days i'm financially free
i've got eight grand in the bank and i'm
going to be a homeowner so it's just
amazing thank you
i'm really proud of you thank you so
much
you've been amazing man honestly bless
you thank you guys
get on the crash course that's where
it's all started everything starts with
the property investors crash
it does it does thank you samuel you're
a good man you're a good man
thank you welcome i'm going to build a
portfolio i'm going to build a really
strong
net worth through property and i'm just
so thankful
to samuel for coming and helping me
through this journey just from grand
celebrating on glenn's financial freedom
i heard man congrats
super well done for for the trip knowing
what i know
now if i had to do this all over again
without
samuel living in my house i know that i
could do it because
i've got the knowledge and the skills to
do it
and no one can ever take that away from
me you do not have to work
nine to five for 40 years for 40 hours a
week
to retire on 40 of what you couldn't
afford to live on in the first place
you do not need to do that and i think
that glenn has demonstrated
that anyone can do this and
i'm just absolutely over the moon and
i'm so pleased for him
and we are now in possession of the keys
officially
and i'm really proud of glenn every time
i've asked him to do something he's done
it
i don't think i could have done much
better myself i'm i'm shocked at how
much has been achieved
the amount of deals that have been done
in these last seven days
is just incredible i'm just so thankful
to samuel
for coming and helping me through this
journey but it has been the hardest work
i have ever done in my life before
samuel came here this week this whole
situation surrounding my tumor
and my health was a real problem it
controlled my life it
dominated my mind every single waking
second
and really it defined who i was as a
person
and yet this week i've not even thought
about it once i've had such a crazy
shift and i realize
that fear a fear of it and fear of
anything just has no place in my life
anymore so moving forward i'm going to
live
every single day as if it was my last
with love
with power with conviction and i'm just
so blessed that i'm alive today
hello hey
how's it going amazing honestly
everything has changed since you've gone
it's been brilliant
new life love it property i'm i just
feel
i feel unstoppable okay let's talk about
the deals that you've done there
so the lease option agreement yeah did
that go through and did you rent it out
yeah it took me about two weeks to get
everything in place so to
refurbish it and everything i filled it
up from the
the day that the ad went live i filled
the whole thing all four rooms
in 72 hours the whole thing completely
full
you're fantastic how much are you
renting out for it's generated just
short two grand a month now
and in terms of profit i'm making about
eleven hundred pounds a month which is
just ridiculous really
you're managing it yourself yeah that's
fantastic absolutely
you've built me on the deal sourcing
side yeah tell us how much money you've
made
after i went home yeah just by packaging
selling deals
i don't know if you're gonna believe
this but i made twenty one and a half
thousand pounds justin dale sources
that is incredible you
are a property machine right now thanks
man
transformational name i know you've also
had a few deals fall out of bed
yeah yeah there was a few legal problems
uh so i kept up my relationship with cam
it's a real key relationship
um and only two weeks ago he got in
touch with me and said i've got eight
units that are actually in a better
location than the ones that we saw
to the same standard and so i'm going to
be taking them on moving forward
great i know you've also you've also
lost out as well you had a bad deal
right
yeah i'll put that yeah well i'll put
nine thousand pound down on a house
auction that ended up being
uh the largest subsiding house the
structural engineers have ever seen so i
lost money on that deal
but since then i've i've joined the
academy uh the people there are
absolutely amazing i feel part of a
really good
uh community but really ultimately it
all starts at the free crash course that
you do
honestly it's just incredible changed my
life mate it really has yeah
and living with you was fantastic as
well and i'm glad that overall things
are going really well are you
completely financially free technically
now then and the rest
and the rest mate i'm really really
pleased for you thank you you're a
wonderful guy
thank you you too thank you samuel from
strength
cheers buddy enjoy your holiday see you
later see you later
[Music]
guys thank you so much for watching the
video i hope you found that really
useful and interesting
please do subscribe below so you don't
miss a future video
also if you'd like to go and do this for
yourself i'd love to follow your journey
on social media
so use the hashtag myff challenge
tag me and i'll follow your journey if
you'd like to receive
training i do run a free two-day
property investors crash course
i'd love to invite you along we're here
actually now at the property investors
crash course
is the training good folks
[Applause]
[Music]
so get yourself booked on the crash
course subscribe below i'll see you on
the next video thank you so much